Hello,
and welcome to Rawkode Live.
Today, I am joined by Julius, the cofounder
of Prometheus, the founder of PromCon,
and newly founder of PromLabs, the creator of
PromLens.
Today, we're gonna be taking an introductory look
at Prometheus
and who best to have join me than
Julius. Hello, Julius. How are you? Hi there.
How's it going?
I I love your intro.
Thank you very much. Yeah. I took a
lot of inspiration from the IT crowd if
you've seen that before. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
And yeah. I I some days I love
it, some days I hate it. And what's
very consistent though is that I can never
start off the introduction properly and always mince
my words. So that's now just a feature
of the show, which. Oh, interesting. When you
were speaking, I was just thinking like, oh,
wow. You you have such a nicely collected
introduction in your head.
Yeah. Yeah. It's it's all of a say
it, and say it is very different. But
I'm I enjoyed this. I'm really looking forward
to today as we take a kinda look
at Prometheus and the the problems that it
solves and and really get people that
you know, Prometheus one zero one. Like, where
do I get started? What does it do?
And how can I make it better? So
do you want to just quickly start by
telling us what Prometheus
is?
Sure.
I would say Prometheus is a monitoring system
first and foremost, which is based on a
time series
database that it includes internally.
And
so it's really yeah. It's a time series
based monitoring
system for monitoring your IT infrastructure,
your services,
but also your devices,
like, devices,
hosts,
potentially anything, actually, that can serialize data in
the format that Prometheus expects. So people also
monitor
their homes with it, like humidity, temperature, or
wind farms, what's the current, like, power that
they output, anything really that you can press
into these kind of time series.
But, really, it got born initially,
by myself and Matt Proud at SoundCloud coming
from Google and missing a proper monitoring system
for more dynamic environments. So SoundCloud already had
a cluster scheduler very early on in 02/2012.
And,
basic the key aspect that Prometheus brings to
those environments is integrating with service discovery in
such a way that Prometheus constantly
has an updated view of what things should
be where. And it's a pull based monitoring
system,
so it actively
not only knows which things should be where,
but also how to reach them and pull
metrics from them over HTTP.
So whether that's your application server, your networking
device, or anything else, as long as it
can serve an HTTP endpoint in the Prometheus
metrics format,
then Prometheus can collect data from it, store
it in a time series database,
and then you can make use of that
collected data
either with dashboarding, maybe showing nice stats,
what's going on overall in your system, or
actually also basing alerts on that collected data.
So you can actually wake people up at
night if if the website is down, if
it's slow, if something else is broken, if
your windmill doesn't output power anymore, for example.
And,
yeah, it comes with a dimensional data model.
So, there's a metric name,
and then a set of key value pairs
that we call labels similar to Docker labels
or Kubernetes labels,
that really give you the different sub dimensions
of a metric name, like the number of
HTTP
requests that have been counted
on a given server but then broken up
by a method,
status code,
something else, etcetera, and the process it came
from.
So you you collect data in that data
model,
and then it goes together with a query
language called PromQL, which we're going to talk
more about, I guess,
which really makes use of that data model
where you can, you know, slice and dice
your data as people love saying. So really
select exactly the data you want and then
aggregate it by any of that dimensionality
that you have,
but also do more complex operations between whole
sets of time series, like binary operations between
sets of time series,
different transformations,
taking rates over counters,
filtering, etcetera, etcetera. So pretty flexible.
And, yeah, I guess, I mean, that's basically
it. So you have the data model. You
have the pull based collection. You have the
query language.
It's pretty efficient in its implementation.
I do have to say, though, Prometheus itself,
the vanilla Prometheus,
is
explicitly not a horizontally
scalable
cloud
thing cluster based thing where you just press
a button after adding more machines, and it
just naturally scales up.
Prometheus
itself is
a single host server of which you can
run multiple that run-in loose federations doing different
things.
But we explicitly wanted to avoid
complex clustering in the system because a lot
of things can go wrong in complex clustering,
and
we basically want Prometheus to be very reliable
and simple in its architecture and not get
stuck on, like, some replication or not being
able to talk to other cluster members or
so. So, you know, if you want high
availability in Prometheus, you just run two of
the same server. They do the same collection,
the same alert computation,
and then later on, you have a component
called the alert manager, which actually deduplicates
things for you. But they don't actually talk
to each other, like the two replicas doing
the same thing. So I guess that's important
to understand.
Of course, then you don't really wanna overwhelm
those two identical replicas because then both break.
But So that that's kind of the core
philosophy,
but then there's also reimplementations
of Prometheus
that take different trade offs. There's, for example,
Cortex
initially started by Weaveworks. Now it's more dominant,
I guess,
lead led by Grafana Labs and others where
the trade off in Cortex is, yeah, we
want to have something like Prometheus but more
horizontally scalable.
Basically,
you just add more machines, press a button,
and it still works.
But it comes with with different trade offs.
It's it's a it's a way bigger beast
to operate.
Awesome. That is a fantastic overview.
And I'm I'm looking forward to diving into
each of those different components, particularly PromQL.
I know from the events that I go
through that it's a it can be a
little bit difficult for some people to reason
around it. And I'm hoping we can just
simplify that for them today.
There's there's a question that I've always wanted
to ask someone
and I think you're a good person to
answer it. And the question relates to why.
Why would you write your own database?
Like, there must be a certain level of
Your database or a whole own monitoring system?
Well, just the database, but, you know, it
it's it's such a difficult and challenging task
to go into to write, like, a TSTP
specifically here rather than using another database.
I mean, like, when we started out in
02/2012,
at least, we looked at everything that was
out there, and we're really not happy with
any of them in terms of efficiency.
So SoundCloud was using graphite, for example, back
then.
And,
yeah, the format, at least, we're using back
then and also the data model that it
was using, both strictly hierarchical and not dimension
based.
And the query language that goes along with
it were really inflexible and also not efficient
in storage,
not doing exactly what we wanted,
and expecting very regular collection intervals in these
things that Prometheus doesn't have.
And I could say similar things about
almost all of the other areas that ended
up being in Prometheus, like,
yeah, the way yeah, the data model,
UI. Although, I mean, Prometheus is known particularly
for a great UI either at the moment.
That's part of of the reason PromLens is
now starting to exist.
But when we were looking all all these
different areas, how alerts tie into things,
really being integrated into the time series system,
but usually being a separate system like and
so on,
We really wanted to have, like, have it
work different in all of those aspects,
so we were really kind of stuck with
building our own.
By now, I think there are
probably, like, more alternatives
that we maybe could base ourselves on. But,
you know, PromQL and the way it selects
data
and does certain things, it also has certain
specific,
both, I think, requirements to the TSDB, but
also
things that can leave out that more general
databases
would have to support. Like, for example, if
you look at InfluxDB,
it supports all kind of data types, etcetera,
etcetera, but that makes it necessarily a way
more complex code base versus what we have
in Prometheus, which is exactly optimized
towards purely numeric time series,
exactly
this label based data model and nothing else.
So it's really, really well optimized towards that
currently. And, also,
what you had previously,
in more static environments where things weren't changing
around so much, you had more long lived
time series,
where you have your server and you just
like, you monitor it and you see the
CPU usage over a year or whatever.
And,
the time series sticks around for a long
time, though. Now what you have on Kubernetes
clusters, especially,
since
the pod name and
certain other ephemeral identifiers become part of your
time series identity, so as part of a
label,
the actual time series
that exists at any given point of time
change all the time. So you need to
index them in a way more efficient way
that is suited for this more dynamic world,
and that was also not really much the
case back then with time
series databases.
Yeah. Well, I mean, I I applaud you
for doing it. It's one of those things.
I think, personally, for me, having looked into
writing my own database just as a as
a hobby and fun to learn is one
of the most daunting tasks I think I've
ever tried to to take on. So Yeah.
I mean, I I gotta say, I mean,
I started we started out with a really
inefficient,
dumb implementation,
and then we went through separate
several
revisions,
including, like, a complete
re architecting that works completely different, which is
the current storage.
And that has become way, way better than
than the previous iterations at actually,
yeah, indexing,
changing series over time, and so on and
so on. And there's now just many companies,
full time employing people who are
at least part time, you know, really doing
great contributions to making the TSTP, like, way
more memory efficient,
faster lookups, and so on and so on.
So it's it's gotten really much better over
the last couple of years.
Nice.
And so we do have our first question,
so I'm gonna pop that up. But we
have a question from Ilya who's asking,
could we could you have used an OSQL
database? Would that have worked? What or or
did you or do you need to use
something that is specific for time series data?
I mean, we started with that with local
host level DB, so we didn't wanna have
anything that's
over the network or so. We wanted to
as I said, initially, a simple architecture
where it's a single process owning everything locally
that you can rely on. So if the
network breaks down, your monitoring system at least
can still work.
So a lot of the network based stuff
wasn't really that attractive for us, and we
wanted it to be simple to operate, kind
of built in to go. So but, yeah,
initially, we we had LevelDB, which is an
in process key value store, and we based
our indexes on that. And you can do
that, but it's at least the design that
we had initially that I came up with
wasn't too great.
And
it it didn't deal well with
with this changing indexing
of series over time.
And
the current database that Fabian came
up with with the design is just a
complete rewrite from scratch, encoding everything exactly how
we need it after already having many years
of experience what exactly we do need.
And,
yeah, I I think I'm not able, like,
to dive too deeply into the theory of
why
a particular
underlying NoSQL database would work well or not
because I'm not too much of an actual
database expert.
But, yeah, I can only say that the
current revision of what we have, which doesn't
use one anymore, works way better than what
we
Yeah. And I think the point you made
earlier as well is really important here is
that the
time to live or how long we keep
around our monitoring data or time series data
is drastically different to maybe, like, a no
a no SQL store as well. And that,
you know, we have to be able to
deprecate or kill off that data on a
regular interval and the sharding model can all
change like yeah. There's a lot of bet
lot of database to do there. Yep. So
why
don't we
install Prometheus?
Like, let's let's show people how it works.
So I have the prometheus.i0
website here.
Mhmm.
Now have we just figure it out without
me telling you anything.
Yeah.
Sure. I mean, I'm what I'm thinking here
is do we wanna jump straight into the
02/22 RC, or should we play it safe
and go with the 02/21?
I think it shouldn't matter. I think this
the RC should be pretty fine, but either
is totally fine. It's not a lot of
changes in the latest version.
Alright. So I have a Linux machine here.
Hopefully, with Carl, that's a good start.
And I will just download.
Perfect.
What did I get wrong there?
Let me try again.
Oh, there's a redirect. Okay. So
let me oh, what's the flag for the
redirect? It's dash l? Isn't it yeah. Just
capital l. I think capital l. Right?
This
isn't supposed to be the difficult part. There
we go. Nothing
would go wrong today. Okay. Let me actually
check.
W get. Doesn't matter. Sorry, Carl. I'm not
I'm no longer your friend. So
we can extract this
and if we go in here,
upper binaries. So right away when we untar
this fail, we've got Prometheus binary and a
prompt tool.
Yeah. Actually, that's maybe the the first thing
that we should do is delete stuff we
don't need in here, which is completely optional,
like delete license notice console libraries and consoles.
And you'll need the dash r, yeah, for
the console
stuff.
Those are kind of optional things like the
consoles, the kind of HTML templates you can
serve directly
from the Prometheus server. It's a very niche
use case. Almost never nobody uses it. So
this is the the remaining three files are
kind of what you actually need or actually
only need the Prometheus binary and a configuration
file, which is YAML in true cloud manner,
which we all love, of course. And
the prompt tool is kind of just like
a side helper tool. For example, you can
use it in CI checks to verify that
a configuration file is really valid before you
apply it to your Prometheus server or check
it into production.
And it can do some other linting and
and helping things, but we don't really need
it probably today.
So the core thing, you have a go
binary.
It will store its data locally in a
directory that you tell it to. By default,
it will just be dot slash data
in the current directory.
And the configuration
file, it that is there, its main job
is to tell Prometheus
what
endpoints to scrape and how to label the
data coming from those endpoints. I mean, there's
some other settings as well in the config
file.
It will tell us, if if we do
that at some point, how to talk to
the alert manager to actually send alert notifications,
how to send data to a remote storage
system if you want to keep it for
later,
etcetera,
etcetera. But the main thing that we'll be
dealing with
is basically the the scraping the scrape configs,
which you see at the bottom. Maybe just
for our demo, let's change the global scrape
interval to five seconds so we see results
and changes coming in faster.
So, you know, in in production, that's a
pretty aggressive scrape interval. Typically, you go for
maybe fifteen seconds to a minute or so.
Sometimes
people do a second, but that's you know,
you need to have the capacity for that.
Yep. So this means Prometheus,
by default, will go out every five seconds
to every target, as we call it, these
endpoints that it knows about, and collect the
current value of each metric from there.
And, yeah, in this default configuration here, you
see Prometheus only scraping one thing, and that's
itself. So Prometheus,
obviously, also
exposes metrics about itself on port nineteen ninety
where it also runs its web interface.
And,
yeah, this this this setup, as you see
it here, is completely useless. It will just
monitor itself, but it's a good way to
start and see if everything's working.
Awesome. So you're saying
we got a default config for scraping every
five seconds for scraping ourselves. So I could
just run.
Just run Prometheus. Maybe maybe one one additional
flag to add that would be nice was
your current what, like, if you
there are certain links in the Prometheus web
interface where Prometheus links back to itself.
And if you are like, if this is
kind of a virtual machine you're running and
if it's thinks it's local host, but if
you click the link and it doesn't really
bring you to that Prometheus because it's in
a VM or so, then we could tell
Prometheus
what its externally
visible URL is. So for example, from your
main host that you run your browser on,
it will be reachable under
my VM port nineteen ninety or IP something
something.
So,
these backlinks to itself, we can tell it
how to generate them properly. So
So this is a bare metal machine on
Equinix Metal. It is publicly available, but I'm
assuming we're okay because the Prometheus interface is
is read only. Is that correct? Yeah. That
that's fine. Yeah. Unless you enable the admin
interface and so on. Yeah. Yeah. By default,
it will be read only. People can DDoS
it, but I hope they won't.
So if you do dash dash dash and
then web dot external
dash URL
equals,
and then you need to provide the whole
URL. So it's like HTTP.
Yep.
And then nineteen ninety
should be correct. Yep. And then Prometheus will
know to modify the links to itself. Nice.
So, hopefully, we should yeah. We we see
it starting up.
It gives you a bit of a blurb
about versions. No errors. Good.
Let's
let's
maybe switch directly to the new UI. You
see the link in the top right there
in new. It's it just looks a bit
nicer already.
The old UI will go away soon.
And if you head to the very top
and click on status
and
targets, we want to be able to see
that it actually scrapes the one target it
knows about, which is Prometheus itself.
So in this case, if you click on
that local host link,
yep,
it see, now it actually applied this local
host
external URL trick.
So here, we can actually now see
the metrics exposed by Prometheus about its own
internal operations. It's written in Go, so it'll
tell you about, like, garbage collection, how many
go routines there are, etcetera, etcetera.
If you scroll further down, there will be
more metrics that are prefixed with Prometheus underscore,
and those will be more Prometheus specific, like
how many samples have I collected,
something about like, way more stats about its
internal TSDB,
how many targets, etcetera, etcetera.
By the way, there is a Chrome plugin,
which is really cool. It's called Prometheus
Formatter.
And if you
install it, then you will get this black
and white thing in nice colors and with
a bit better formatting, these metrics endpoints.
I don't know if you wanna install that
now, but it's it's I have it, and
I always always
I love it. Prometheus
Chrome
extension.
Why not? If it's if it's It's called
Prometheus Formatter.
Oh, there we go. There we go. Yeah.
Yeah.
Today,
I learned.
And it just makes it look a bit
nicer. Hopefully, it's not virus infected. Ta da.
Oh, that was nice.
Hopefully, it's not very thank you for that
as I just installed it on my Chrome
browser.
This is not investment advice. Okay.
So yeah. So it looks, you know, much
more readable already and much more friendly. So
what we see here is the data model
that I talked about.
Conceptually,
what happens in this format? So
when you go to this endpoint,
the process
that
you get metrics from
is basically instructed to
to serialize its current value
of each of the time series that it's
currently tracking into the Prometheus format. So you
get exactly the current value
of each of the time series in
that Prometheus is tracking about itself.
So it's not about what it has in
its TSTB.
So there's there's not really history included here,
like, what was the value
a minute ago or so.
Basically, the history is only built by Prometheus
itself coming along every five seconds in this
case and storing that history in its time
series database.
But every time it comes to this page,
it only sees what's the current value.
So example,
currently, the concurrent maximum queries that are allowed
is 20, or and currently, there's zero ongoing
prompt Prometheus engine queries.
And, like, if you reload the page, the
next time it might have a value of
one there or five or so, and then
Prometheus will just store
that current value.
Especially those counters that you see, like
something something
seconds count.
Yeah. For example, that one. This is a
metric that Prometheus will only see go up.
So if you refresh this page a couple
of times,
then
you will only see that metric going up.
It's like the total number of seconds that
the Go runtime
has spent
doing garbage collection since this process started. So
these counters can reset, but only if the
process that exposes them and track them also
actually restarts because they're only kept in memory.
Yep. So this so, basically, one line, one
sample
metric name, and then the label values,
and then the actual sample value at the
very end.
Okay. So let's let's just break that down
what you just said there. So this is
we call this the metric name?
Yep. So the metric name is kind of
the fundamental
aspect of the system that you're monitoring. In
this case
yeah. This is a summary. It's maybe a
bit more complex, but let's look at the
very simple metric, go go routines.
It's the aspect there is, yeah, you're measuring
the number of go routines.
In this case, there are not even any
sub dimensions, so labels
on that metric, but some metrics do.
If you scroll a bit further down, maybe
we'll find, like, a good simple one, like,
boom, further, further, further until we see something
with more labels that that's not a summary
or yep. Yeah. Let's let yep. Yep. Yep.
Mhmm. This this is good because it's still
just the simple counter metric, so always the
same metric name.
So contract
failed
connection dialings,
but with different four different subdomain. So this
counts
for each of these dialer names and reasons
how many of these failures have happened.
And
then
yeah. And then you have the space, and
then you have the actual current value of
each of these time series.
So each time series is identified
by the metric name
and the unique set of labels following it.
So each line is one time series in
Prometheus lingo.
Okay. So we got metric names, we've got
labels,
and we got the value. What is the
different metric types that we have for them,
Prometheus? And I see that we've got access
to something called a counter. We also had
a gauge. There was a summary. I mean,
what what are these different types of metrics?
Yeah. Oh, I actually just gave a talk
about that a couple of days or last
week ago or so ago.
So metric types are
yeah. We we have four of them, gauge,
summary,
counter, and histogram, and they're a bit different
ways of measuring different aspects of your system.
So, for example, a counter is a metric
that can only go up,
because it's used for counting cumulative totals of
either requests that you process or total number
of seconds spent in
certain CPU mode or something like this.
So those are metrics that only go up.
And we have a convention
that we we end them with underscore total.
That's that's why this metric is named like
that, but it's only a convention,
but people should follow it.
The gauge is a metric that can go
naturally up or down.
So memory usage, queue length, etcetera, etcetera.
And then you have histograms
and summaries.
So is this a histogram
is used for
tracking the distribution
of a set of values across a number
of histogram buckets.
So the most you the the most common
case is request durations
that you're measuring in your process as you're
handling requests.
You might want to record
how many of which latency category you have
seen.
So, yeah, this is a histogram example here.
It's not a particularly beautiful one, but, yeah,
it it will serve our purpose. So in
this case,
it you know, when when you actually track
these
when when you track things into histogram in
your process that's handling a request, you have
a single object
where you you create a histogram saying, I
want to have a histogram,
and it will have this the following bucket
configuration.
So latency bucket going from zero to, in
this case, you know, one hundred milliseconds and
one from zero to two hundred milliseconds, one
from zero to four hundred milliseconds. So it's
a cumulative histogram. Every bucket starts at zero
and thus includes the counts
of previous buckets,
but then has a given upper bound.
So you create that object
in your client library, and then every time
you actually handle the request
of a given duration, you just call a
method on that histogram, say, observe. And you
say, observe
two hundred milliseconds. Observe
one hundred fifty milliseconds or so. And, internally,
the histogram will then increment counters
for each of the buckets that are relevant
to that event you have just observed.
So each of these,
so that's one object in the client library
as you're tracking things. But then when it
gets serialized
out in this text format, we have to
kinda spread it out into different time series.
So the
TSDB in Prometheus
doesn't really have a clue about what a
histogram is. It only knows the scheme of,
like, metric name,
a bunch of label pairs, and the sample
value. So we kind of have to,
yeah, serialize it into that format. So the
way we do that is just expose each
of those buckets of the histogram as a
separate time series with the underscore bucket appended
to the original base name of your metric.
And then we have the LE label on
there. It stands for less than or equal,
which means it's like
every request gets counted into this bucket that
has a latency of less than or equal
to sixty seconds.
And
yeah. And and so, basically, this this histogram
gets kind of expanded into this form.
You also get two other auxiliary
output metrics in the serialization,
which is this underscore sum and underscore count.
This is just the total count
of all observations you've made, so total count
of all requests,
and the total amount of seconds you have
spent
in handling all those requests.
So you could
get the average latency by dividing
the sum by the count, for example.
Alright. Yeah. So that that's a histogram. A
summary is and and so, by the way,
like, you typically wouldn't then later on, like,
look at a histogram in its raw form.
In PromQL, you would run a function over
it called histogram quantile
to
calculate
quantiles from histogram or at least approximate them
because it's never going to be perfect.
It depends on the resolution of your buckets.
But then you can
ask questions such as what what's my 90
percentile latency
over the entire system or at a given
aggregation level?
A quantile is something that directly
a summary is a metric type that
in the client library already computes these quantiles
for you. So directly from the process, as
we see here, we get the the minimum,
the maximum,
and and the, you know, twenty fifth quant
percentile
and fifties and so on. The downside is
I mean, the the upside is you directly
get a really well computed quanta, which has
little error. And if you compute it using
directly the summary type and, for example, the
Go client library,
it
you can specify
the absolute error margin you want to have
in the result.
The downside is that you cannot aggregate over
quantiles at all. It's just statistically
invalid.
So
if you have 10 processes and they each
expose their
ninetieth percentile latency, let's say, you have no
idea what the total system's ninetieth percentile latency
is. You cannot average over them. It gives
you statistically nonsensical
results,
but you can do the same with histograms.
So
but those, you know, they they're they can
be more expensive. If you want to have
a good approximation of quantiles from histogram, you
need many fine grained buckets in exactly the
right latency places.
So it's a really tricky subject. There's a
page in the Prometheus best practices docs that
really goes deeper into that comparison if if
someone wants to look at that more.
But most of the time, you wanna look
at systems in aggregate, so you kind of
have to use
histograms.
Okay. Awesome. That's a a really great explanation
of those four metric types. I'm kind of
curious between the gauge and the counter. Are
there any optimizations that are made in the
database level
because you know the account or can't
climb down? Like, why is there that distinction
there?
Yep. So at the database level, the database
has no idea.
It doesn't know about metric types, period.
It does already just, you know, do,
gorilla styles or float compression on sample values
and so on. So if they for example,
if a sample value stays the same all
the time or increases very regularly or so,
that already compresses very well,
but it has no idea about the the
type.
The only so that that's it's just basically
you know, maybe if we were doing Prometheus
completely from the ground up or if there's
a Prometheus three dot zero at some point,
we could think about
making these metric types more first class, storing
them
better and more efficiently directly in the database.
Even a histogram could be stored way better,
right, instead of, like, separate time series. It
could be one time series with different buckets
stored more efficiently.
And then also make PromQL itself more aware
of that because currently, it's not directly aware
of metric types. There are functions that expect
input times used to behave like a counter
or like a gauge or like a histogram,
but the function cannot actually
ask the TSDB, like, is this the right
metric type?
Okay. I guess Yeah.
That leads us on to a question we
have from Elliot in the chat.
It just says, is the the metric types
purely convention and are there any plans to
maybe make them strongly typed in the future?
And I think you kind of maybe just
answered that a little bit there. If there's
a three point o. Well, it is kind
of a
in some places so there's a whole chain,
like instrumentation,
collection,
processing of the data in the TSDB, and
then PromQL.
And in some parts of that chain, they're
more than a convention. They're an actual code
level object,
and that's the strongest in the instrumentation library
where you really say, I want a new
gauge. I want a new summary. And you
get different methods,
depending on
which type of metric you created. On the
counter, you get an increment method, but no
set method. On the gauge, you get a
set method on a etcetera.
And then in the text format, in this
exposition format, it's already slightly weaker. It's there
in these kind of commented things that get
slightly ingested by the Prometheus server, but not
really don't really make it all the way
into the TSDB. There's currently it keeps it
it's kind of for the longest time, it
didn't do anything with it, but then now
it stores this help and type information in
memory, and you can query it
from like, for Grafana or PromLens or other
UIs that then actually surface this information for
the metric names for users.
But then the TSDB, it's completely lost again.
And then when you work with stuff in
PromQL, you basically have to know what metric
is what, and that's why it's important to
name your metrics
according to conventions.
Because, for example, there's the rate function, and
the rate function gives you the per second
increase of a counter metric.
And,
when it sees a counter
going up and up and up and then
down,
it assumes, oh, that was a process restart
and and reset of the counter and not,
like, something that could have happened naturally.
So it will act as if that reset
hadn't happened and kind of neutralizes it in
a way. So if you stick a gauge
metric that is, memory usage or so into
the rate function,
the rate function will think, like, whenever the
memory usage goes down, oh, that's a counter
reset. I act as if it doesn't happen.
I will only return you, like, positive rates.
So you'll need to use the derivative function
for gauges instead.
So, yeah, that's important to know.
Awesome. Excellent.
So I think Agree.
So
let's I think the next step, and if
you agree, let's go down that path. We
should add an exporter now. Like, we want
something Yeah. Maybe slightly more substantial than the
metrics that Prometheus has exposed in itself. Yep.
Yep. I mean, we could already start querying
the metrics about Prometheus itself. We can see,
like, how many
samples it is ingesting about itself per second,
for example,
as a good start.
So if you go to yeah. Yep.
So if you just type, I think, head
underscore
append,
it should fuzzy find the right thing,
and then the sample the second one.
So this is the metric name. And in
PromQL, if we just give the name of
metric name,
then it will return all the metrics all
the time series that have that metric name.
In this case, it's only one. So this
the total is a countermetric,
underscore top total, which tells us the total
number of samples that this process has ingested
so far into its t s t s
TSTB.
So you could switch over to the graph
tab,
and we see it going up over time.
Right? So it's a counter. So this is
completely useless.
The one thing about counters is you basically
never wanna care about the absolute value. You
always wanna rate them or do something with
them. So let's wrap a function around it
called the rate function.
And,
yeah, if you go to the very end,
you will need to provide the time window
to average the rate over, and you do
that after the metric name in these angle
what are they called? Square brackets.
Straight. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Mhmm. Exactly like this.
So this would give you the
per second
number of ingested samples
but averaged over one minute of ingestion.
So we see it currently at hundred something
samples per second. So now if we add
an actual second target, like, node exporter, we
should see this number go up.
Okay. So we want to deploy the node
exporter to our machine. Yes. Let's do it.
Alright. Let's see. We do more complicated Prometheus,
could probably start using PromLens because it's less
of a pain.
K. So we have
node exporter.
I'm
just gonna go to releases
and grab
Linux here.
How to split this?
Mhmm.
Is that my IP address?
We'll find out.
Yes. It is. Okay. Excellent. So
do we have? We have a license notice
and then a node export. I'm assuming I
just run the binary. Yep. There's tons of
flags, but by default, it will do reasonable
things.
So the node exporter has nothing to do
with Node. Js. It's the node in there
means, like, a network node or compute node,
so a host.
And
it exposes all kinds of metrics that you
would typically expect about a system, CPU memory,
interrupts, etcetera, etcetera, etcetera, network.
You see a lot of collectors listed here
in the log already,
so you can, you know, you can able
enable collectors, disable them,
enable ones that aren't enabled by default also,
configure them,
have, like, include list, exclude list of what
devices you actually want to include in, like,
network
devices, for example, or or file systems if
you have a lot of these virtual ones
that you don't want to have included. But
by default, it will give you reasonable
information.
So the node exporter mostly gets its information
from the proc and sys file systems, but
it also does a couple of system calls
to get information
about the machine that's running on. So just
to confirm then, because Prometheus is a pill
based system, our node exporter right now is
exposing an HTTP endpoint on port 9,100.
Yep. And currently, Prometheus is not actually aware
of that. Right? We're we're gonna we're gonna
have to change something? Yep. And so this
is one kind
of cool thing. Like, when Prometheus isn't actually
coming by and scraping, the node export is
just doing nothing. So it's not collecting any
data. It's just
since all the operations it does are so
cheap
and only take, like, milliseconds or so, it
can do them synchronously.
The moment it scraped, it just, like, goes
to all these proxies files,
parses them, translates them to Prometheus metrics, and
feeds them back to Prometheus. So, yeah, we
would now need to go into the Prometheus
configuration file
and add another
scrape configuration.
And so just one comment. So, currently, we
have completely static configurations
of targets in this config file.
Where Prometheus' power becomes way way larger is
when you have it,
for example, in a Kubernetes cluster and you
don't configure any target manually, you just say,
like, talk to the Kubernetes API server, get
all pods you know,
and then use a certain labeling scheme to
identify them and scrape everything.
So that's that and then it keeps itself
up to date. But in this case, we're
just gonna do static targets.
Yeah. So if you just copy the first
scrape config, and then we can modify it
a bit.
So let's call it node. Yep. And use
the node exporter part.
Yep. Mhmm.
Yep.
Mhmm.
Easy. And
so you can either restart your Prometheus server,
which I I guess now you already killed
it anyway, or you could also send it
a hop signal or reload it over the
web if you have the admin APIs enabled.
But yeah. Oh, nice. Reloading
or restarting works as well. But it's, of
course, not something you would typically do want
to do in production. You wanna, like, reload
the config. Everything in the config is reloadable
during the run time. Yeah. I just don't
wanna cancel the territory of of too many
splits on my screen. So I was quite
happy Yeah. Yeah. I'm gonna bring it back.
Makes sense. Makes sense. Let's go to
our status
targets again.
Yep.
Nice.
So we have two.
We should actually, if you just use the
browser back button, we should go go get
back to the query. And now if we
graph that again yeah. We see a brief
outage there because Prometheus was down, and now
we see the
scrape rate going up.
Yep. Perfect.
Yep.
And now
if you actually,
should we should we start
querying using PromLens right away? It's just so
much nicer PromQL interface.
It's a built in one. I don't wanna
just, like, plug my stuff. But No. No.
No. Show me the way. Show me the
good stuff. Okay.
So
the
freebie kind of preview version of PromLens that
is just hosted directly on promlens.com,
you can actually just
plug in
your,
yeah, that URL as long as your browser
can
oh, see, that's that's the downside, though.
You would need to be able to reach
it over HTTPS because prometheus.com
is served over HTTPS,
and the browser is not allowed to do,
mixed content AJAX. So,
that's, yeah, that's the downside. You could you
could run it locally,
though, if you do just, a docker run
PromLens slash PromLens.
K. Let's do that. So I'm gonna do
your tab. Docker container. One exposed one exposed
port, which is eighty eighty.
That all I need? Yeah. I think that's
all that you need. Yeah.
Oh, and Docker, of course.
Let's check on our level. You'll you'll see
why why I said that. It's it's gonna
be much nicer to work with PromQL.
So the the main reason is actually the
text editor,
which is currently in PromLens, which is just
but the current Docker version doesn't have the
very newest stuff yet. Too bad.
It's still better than
still better than the build in one. But
the text editor will also end up being
in Prometheus OSS, just the rest of the
PromLens features will not. So
Yeah. The port goes first. So let me
Yeah.
I know better.
So you were saying I can just set
local host on a Yeah.
Yeah.
And now if you just paste the server
there and yeah. If you just unfo yep.
So that works. Cool. So now we can
just type the same metric that we had
before for or let's let's explore node export
metrics. So if you type node
yep.
So the up to date version would also
show you,
help strings and type information and all that
here. We don't have that yet.
So,
yeah, we could take we could start with
the CPU usage, for example, which is the
second metric you see here.
And if you just press return and you
you can graph it below, you get a
bunch of CPU usage counters.
So what you see here is the total
number of seconds spent in each CPU mode
and in each core and in each process,
but we only have one node exporter process.
So that's not really
useful dimensionality
for us. So the the main things are
the CPU label and the mode label.
And so,
yeah, we could now so
they are counters, so the absolute value doesn't
really help us. So PromLens already suggests you
to add the rate function here. So it
kind of auto detects this is probably a
counter.
And now if you graph it,
you will actually see proper CPU usage.
Why does it make sense? I have to
maybe explain why it makes sense to use
the rate function on CPU usage seconds. So
what is this? So imagine
you only have one core and one mode
to make it more simple. Right? You have,
like, a CPU usage, and it can be
between zero and one.
And
imagine your CPU is at 100%
usage. Then
per second,
it would spend one second of CPU usage.
Right?
And
if it's at 0% use, it would spend
zero seconds for per second c in in
the CPU.
So
if we take the per second rate over
this counter,
this is basically giving us the usage in
course
per
mode and per core.
So if you have multiple cores and sum
over them, you might actually get like, if
you have four cores, you might get a
number up to four.
You could multiply it then by a hundred
to get to percentage.
And
yep. So you probably wanna zoom out a
bit in in the graph or or zoom
in rather pressing the minus button.
This one. Because we don't have a lot
of data collected yet in the Prometheus server.
So
just there, you you see, for example, idle.
Most most of it like, it's almost 100%
idle mode, and then you have a tiny
bit of usage in the in the other
modes weighed on there,
user and and system and so on.
And,
yeah, you have a bunch more metrics about
the machine coming from the node exporter.
Okay. So it's that's the special yeah. That
specialization
is is really great, and I love the
fact that it offered to add that rate.
That I mean, that's I just don't live
very very well. I haven't really talked much
about PromLens itself yet. It was just like,
I I can't my personally, I can't really
use the
I can't really use PromLens PromQL without PromLens
anymore. So I'm just like but
so PromLens,
to give a bit of a background. So,
I mean, I I freelanced the last four
years around Prometheus just doing consulting,
training, custom development for companies.
And this year, I I decided,
hey. I have a really cool idea for
a new prompt query builder tool that should
exist, but I can't really justify
just building it completely in my free time
and not even, you know, trying to do
something commercial out of it. And so I
created a company, PromLens,
and PromLens
is kind of my first venture into this
whole
business of, yeah, trying commercial software.
So it's meant to be run on premise
as a docker container, and you give it
a license key, and then it can enable
features such as at the top where you
currently have to manually enter your Prometheus server.
It can actually talk to Grafana, and it
will give you a selector of all the
Prometheus data sources in your Grafana installation.
It also allows you to create entire shared
links
that you can send around on Slack and
so on to query pages.
The main value of this tool is,
like, it's basically a PromQL
power tool, I would say,
because, a, the text editor from the prompt
PromQL is way great greater than what's currently
in Prometheus, though I'm I want to open
source that, bring that into Prometheus as well.
But
what it gives you is once you have
more complex queries with different binary operations and
filters and so on and so on,
in
just the text version, it becomes really hard
at some point to understand
in which different sub selector and sub query
is it selecting what data and why what
labels on that sub selector,
etcetera, etcetera, etcetera.
So
what it does is it visualizes
the query that you input as a tree
here,
with every sub expression becoming its own tree
note and telling you what labels are on
that tree note and,
with what cardinalities.
So, for example, you got 48
different values for the CPU
label in this case.
And,
yeah, shows you how many results there are.
So you can really, really quickly spot, like,
oh, in this sub selector,
there's actually, like, zero results, so the entire
expression will never return anything.
It will also tell you if there's an
error, like, where exactly that for example, a
group by matching error happens in your tree.
I had one consulting session with a client
where I had access to their Prometheus server,
and then we went
I shared my screen. We went through all
of their alerting rules,
which are important to work correctly,
and half of them were broken. And we
could like, I just copy and pasted them
into PromLens. And in PromLens, we could see
pretty much immediately, like, oh, yeah. This sub
selector is, like, not even the right metric
name. It always select zero series, so, like,
this alert will never fire.
And,
yeah. So it gives you a lot of
deeper insights into the structure. Now the other
thing is it also includes a form based
editor. So every note here, you can actually
if you even either press e for edit
or hover over it, and there's, like, a
little icon.
Yeah. You can edit any part of the
query
using completely form based editing. So you can
say, like, I want an aggregation, and I
wanna aggregate over the following labels, etcetera, etcetera.
You could go to snippets, for example,
and also say, hey. I want to calculate
the quantile from histogram. Like, let's maybe just
do that.
Doop doop. And there, yeah, there can be
more snippets in the future. So it fills
out these placeholders,
kind of.
If you press e again, it will close
that.
Oops.
Yeah. You can also add a PromQL inline.
So if you just, like, double click on
a node or
yeah. Then then you can, you know, actually
edit any part of the tree in line
as PromQL
and so on and so on. So, like,
it gives you form based editing. It helps
you in a lot of ways. It gives
you these little quick actions like add rate,
add some to the expression.
Hey. This is a histogram. Are you do
you maybe mean to, like, wrap histogram quantile
around it?
And,
yeah, basically just helps you really understand and
build your PromQL queries way more effectively and
especially
avoid, like, completely broken alerts
that, yeah, are way too common.
Okay. So
that's really, really useful stuff. Let's tackle one
of the questions we have in the chat,
and then why don't we contrive a situation
then? Like, we'll run some processes. Let's try
and, you know, spike the CPUs, the test
usage, and see how we can explore those
metrics with on the note. Yep.
And get people a good feel for for
PromQL
and and PromLens.
So the first question we have, another one
from Elliot, is asking,
can we compare the results from different time
periods? Can I compare the I'm assuming he's
asking if I view the CPU usage now,
can I overlay that with the CPU usage
from an hour ago or ten minutes ago?
Only if you use
yeah. Not not really. Not in this tool.
It's more for building the query itself and
less for, like, the actual data.
The
yeah. Like, looking at exactly how the data
behaved itself, but more about building the correct
query, I guess.
So you can
so the the thing is the graph tab,
there's only one of them on this page
currently, and it has one time range.
You could theoretically build a prompt query which
selects the current
set of time series for something and then
ors in with a couple of query tricks,
like an offset version of the same query,
but that's a bit cumbersome. Like, that's not
what you would typically do. Yeah.
But what you can do is, like, really
quickly switch what you're looking at. So you
can, like, click with a mouse button on
any of these
query notes. Maybe maybe if you go to
if you go to the hosted PromLens,
you will see it better. So promlens.com.
If
you go to, let's let's say, about
and click on that yeah. Click on this
example page.
So really quickly, you can just, like, click
on the mouse where on any of these
query notes and then see exactly the shape
of the data at any of the notes.
You can also navigate by keyboard with j
k like in Vim.
And,
yep, like this, there's, like, a bunch more
keyboard commands to help you, like, navigate around.
If you press enter, you go into, like,
editing mode, inline editing of that mow node
and so on.
And yeah. Yeah. We figured it out pretty
quickly. So that's it's kind of, like, almost
like a little gauge or tap that you,
yeah, like, stick into the system and see,
like, okay. What's the value at this sub
element here? And whereas, like, if you do
the same thing in the standard just text
editor,
it gets kind of annoying because you have
to, like, copy and paste different parts of
your query into a separate panel, see, like,
what does this evaluate to? And here, you
just, like, can immediately see it.
Also, like, at the very top, if you
type a metric name,
let's say, delete this demo API request duration
seconds bucket.
No. Sorry. Like, in Here. Yeah. In in
there. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. If we just type
bucket, for example.
Here, you see now you get the cut
the the type and the help string. So
if you if you just, like, go up
and down with arrows on your keyboard, you
see, like, the actual metadata
for each of the metrics being surfaced more
nicely. This looks and feels quite familiar. I
mean, is this using Monaco to be as
code?
It used to, and now I styled code
mirror next
in the same way as it looked before
with Monaco. Yeah.
Oh, and there's also an explain tab at
the very bottom that can actually explain the
meaning of any node and sub expression to
you. So
if you head over there, yeah, and then
you select the function call, for example, it
gives you the documentation
for the function,
for the aggregation that explains what it's doing.
If you go on the binary operation,
which is the root
of this entire expression,
the the slash on job thingy Oh, there
we go.
It even shows you, like, how it matches
up left hand side, right hand side.
Maybe I'm overwhelming people a bit if they
didn't do PromQL before
because we didn't talk really about PromQL much
yet.
But I just I guess, I I went
into the mode of, oh, I wanna show
all the features of PromLens,
but I will stop now.
No. I I I I think, you know,
being able to visualize the queries, explain them,
and have all the documentation in mind is
a a really viable tool, especially as people
are learning how to write their first Prometheus,
you know, queries. Like Yeah. A little bit
So So I I wanna use it in
trainings as well for people to understand, like,
why are the queries working or not working,
what exactly does a certain node do, and
so on. Yep.
Okay. So
Okay. Let's I I hand it back over
back to you and stop the commercial section.
No problem. Alright. We will let's so let's
use our Prometheus server, whether or to export
our we have the ability to
to run our PromQL queries and visualize what
we have here.
So
let's try and tackle maybe what would be
you know, if someone is just gonna start
it with the node export or in Prometheus.
Some of the first queries that are popping
into my head are how can I track
the CPU usage
over time or
in fact, here's a story? So I used
to be an
operator
SRE,
you know, over the last kind of five
years. And I always used to get woken
up at three or 4AM in the morning.
And I really, really hate getting woken up
at three or 4AM in the morning. And
one of the the one of the most
regular culprits
was the desk filling up by some bad
actor. And I always thought it'd be really
cool
if I could just use some sort of
linear protection to warn me during office hours
that the desk was gonna fill up in
the evening. Yep.
Now is that something that we could
contrive here, artificially create? Maybe if I run
DD and write out a large file on
his desk, would we be able to track
that usage and see the graph going? So
we we can. Prometheus has the function. And
and by the way, we say also always,
like, if you can avoid it, don't,
yeah, don't alert on these absolute disk usage
values,
but rather try to predict when will your
disk actually be really at zero free state.
And so we have
what we typically do or recommend people to
do is
put
the,
what's the metric called? Like, there's a metric,
the node file system
available
disk something
file system avail bytes.
It's important to use available bytes, not free
bytes because
available excludes
those blocks reserved for the root user.
So you run out of of, yeah, out
of that earlier than just free.
And
plug that into the predict linear function.
So there's a predict underscore linear
for that works on gauges like this.
And you provide it,
first of all, on the metric name itself,
you provide it with these with this square
bracket selector
of how much past
data you want to look at for this
linear prediction. So it does linear regression
over the data points. Typically,
you wanna look over, like, multiple hours. Right?
Let's say, sometimes people do four hours because
disk usage
often, at least, it's not like a very
quickly moving thing.
So let's let's say maybe four hours or
so.
My thoughts were, though, if I'm gonna start
running the the I love a hundred gig,
it's gonna go very quickly. So we maybe
wanna look at it like, seconds so I
can kill it, and then we can just
see that So this won't actually give you
any results because we it it
to do a linear regression, you need at
least two data points to fall under this
window,
and we only scrape at a at a
resolution of five seconds. So to be really
sure, yeah, you want to have at least,
like, fifteen seconds there or something something bit
larger. Like, a minute is yeah. Let's do
a minute.
The second thing the second parameter to this
function is
now that we have this linear regression that
we're doing over this, we can predict this
value into the future. So we can say,
based on the current development
that we've seen over the last,
what, one minute in this case, what will
it be in, let's say, five minutes?
So the the thing there at this point
in this
it expects a normal expression note and not
a duration, so you have to provide it
in
as a normal number.
If we want to say five minutes, you
could do five times 60 or 300. Yeah.
Yeah. So it expects number of seconds to
predict it into the future. And so now
what you get as the output is, like,
the expected
disk usage
in five minutes.
And now we could,
we could add a filter condition and say,
like, only output it to me
if it is expected to be less or
equal to zero. Okay. Just say less than
zero. So if we say less than zero
yep. So this filters the set of output
time series, but only the ones that are
going to be full.
And alerts in Prometheus work in that way
that
the the
the heart of any alerting rule is a
PromQL expression,
which
is expected to output nothing at all if
everything is fine
and
output
one or more time series if there is
a problem. So then every output time series
will be turned into an alert.
So, for example, if there were two tie
two different file systems now for which this
condition is true,
you would get two different alerts, one for
each, unless you, like, aggregate over them in
PromQL or so. But by default,
two output times here is two alerts.
Cool. So, yeah, if we now start filling
up the disc really quickly, this might, at
some point, start telling you
that
Deft, I'm gonna need a new tab now.
And, like, this is one of the situations
where I would then, like, go into PromLens
and see because the filter, right, you you
typically don't see anything anymore as the final
output of the expression.
So then you can still click on the
subnote that shows you the current
trend of the disc usage and see, like,
okay.
Will it even,
like, get close to my filter condition soon,
or do I have to change my filter
and so on?
Okay. Yeah. Let's let's trash the disc.
I'm sure there's a way to specify how
big I want this to write, and I
can't remember what it is.
Yeah. That's block size and the count.
Yeah. Let's just look it up. So It's
just count in BS.
Is it as simple as that? This is
the that not yet. Oh, there we go.
So
yeah.
Okay.
Problem is if if it creates sparse files.
Yeah. DevRandom will not create sparse files. That's
good. Better than DevZero then. Yeah.
Okay. Otherwise, we won't get the disc users
we're expecting.
So
I should be able to run this. That
should create 1,001
meg files. Right?
Yeah.
Which is not a lot, but let's just
should be one meg, basically. Right?
With the current 1,003 The b b s
is already in in kilobytes. Right? Or is
it in bytes? I forgot. Okay. Kilobytes kilobytes.
Okay. Cool. I think.
Alright. So let's let's just see. Right? We
have this query here, so we can
I guess the best thing to do is
just to duplicate this tab? Right? Some bytes.
Some bytes. Okay. Yeah. I guess that actually
makes sense. Way more probably, but yeah.
So See you see what you're doing now?
You have to, like, manually edit away parts
of the query?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
And and Prometheus, you just click on that
subnote, see, like, okay. What's actually returned by
this?
That's exactly why I hate I don't I
don't work in that normal interface anymore. Okay.
So so
what we're saying is we could actually just
use our fail system available by this here.
And then what we had was a predict
predict linear. Yeah. Uh-huh.
We had a one minute and a
three hundred.
Yep. So you're saying I could just filter
the squidgy to just one section? Oh, and
we had the filter condition as well, like,
less than zero.
Yep. And now you can just click on
the notes and see what each subexpression actually
is doing.
Thing is with a range vector, you cannot
graph it because, like, at every point in
time, it would have multiple values. You can
table it. You can you can see, like,
what's the,
yeah. This this is the kind of raw
disk usage over multiple peers in time, but
you can see what the linear prediction of
that is, for example.
So I can filter this using the label
selector, right, to only get the root disk?
Yes. And is that just the case of
adding
Yep. Mhmm.
Yep.
Exactly.
So now you see, okay. Yep. The total
query doesn't return anything, but these subqueries do
return useful
data.
Okay.
Okay. So now I I I do wanna
start filling up this desk. So let me
just confirm what the hell I wrote there.
Slash
random.
That's not the size I was expecting.
Or maybe they can't isn't there what I
want. Let's just write, right now. Yeah. I
mean, the we yes. It's fine. So it
only would have created, like, a tiny
file. Oh, this is even tinier. Yeah.
Yeah. It was smaller than I expected, you
know. So we're I'm just gonna keep writing
with DD. So I guess, indeed, what I
should see now is if I You go
to the graph of predict linear, you will
see the linear prediction of where this will
end up in five minutes should go up
and up,
like, as as very soon now, at least.
Yeah. So we're still waiting on that fifteen
sec fifteen second scrape underflow, and we need
a couple of values underneath the test. Two
samples to actually see the change and yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. So if if you see at
this moment, it looks like it's going down
a lot, but it's not. If you look
at the y axis, it's basically staying the
same.
If you kind of just
yeah.
The the I guess the only real way
to refresh this graph is to either, like,
change one of the settings or
select
should put, like, a refresh button there directly.
Yeah. Yeah. For the sub mode, you know,
if you wanna if you wanna graph the
predict linear directly.
Oh, no. Actually, it should go down
because we're predicting
the available bytes, not the used bytes.
But currently, it's still not doing much. So
is you is the
actual
is it doing much?
Zero bytes copied, so it's not doing anything.
Oh, you wanna probably use dev view random.
Right?
Or because it's faster.
Random bytes.
Just Let's just check if that's working. Okay.
That's right. That's That's right. Yeah. Yeah.
So now we have to we could put
on a clock there. We have to visualize
this before I fill up that disk. Yeah.
Before you before everything crashes and Prometheus runs
into problems.
It's a particular there. I'm using my nice
auto complete here and digging it. You want
verify one minute with 300
less than zero.
Can click on this. I am. I'm I'm
liking this. I'm liking this. Nice.
Now we do okay. So now we started
right into that disk.
We just have to wait for those two
samples to collect now, which is gonna take
ten seconds. Mhmm. Zoom in a bit, like,
do over the last five minutes or so.
Yep.
And I I'm just gonna split this again
so I can actually track the disk usage.
Yeah. That's a good idea. Yeah. And we
wanna make sure that we're really tracking the
right one. So you're writing into root. Yeah.
Oh, no. Wrong one. There we go.
So s t p three, let's just grab.
I don't know what.
It's our desk is filling up. We went
from 6%. We're at 7%.
It's gone up to 6.34.
Okay. Right. Yeah. Yeah.
So this is gonna I think it was
a hundred gigs that said we had three.
Yep. But now that this is slowly filling
up, we should see this graph start to
take shape. Right? Yeah. Yeah. So I guess
the the workaround for not being able to
directly refresh this graph for a particular sub
note is to select the other subnote and
then switch back to predict linear. Or you
can just, like, change the the group the
graph setting or something. Yeah. Why is it
not going down yet?
We should probably try
can you add another query? Press that. Yeah.
Add another query and go directly to node
file system avail bytes.
Oh, yeah. We should also add our root
mount point filter again, I guess.
Oh, yeah. I saw that
point.
Yep. Mhmm.
And so that is not doing much yet.
It's not really
is it x oh, it's dev v d
a.
It's not are you are you sure you're
filling up the right machine's root disk? Because
it down there in the legend,
if you scroll further down, it says
and I think you had
something.
Right?
Oh, am I right into the wrong desk?
Yeah. I think so.
Or am I on the wrong machine?
Yeah. I think you're
Alright. So can we filter by the series?
Like, how do I Like, are we monitoring
the right thing?
CZedJ8CZedJ8.
Will I get the host name from here?
Where is give me a prompt.
Yeah. CZGA.
So we we are on this the same
machine.
It's weird that the desk labels are
different.
But, I mean, this is going down. Right?
This is correct.
Not really. It's going down, like,
couple of bytes
or something. You know? So if you look
at the y axis
and it's a different device name, so
it's it doesn't look like the right device.
So we went from 6% to 13% usage
here.
But if we're we're seeing a drop in
around, what, six six gig?
If you
so I'm a bit confused.
Just can we make sure we're we configured
Prometheus correctly to to scrape from the right
host? Oh, wait. At the very top? Oh,
I think I know what's going on. Okay.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So we we we reloaded
the page.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So
okay.
There we go. Okay.
This makes way more sense. I'm like, what
what's going on? Okay. So yeah. Okay.
We see the disc usage going down or
go So I can remove this query, add
in my label filter again where we only
wanna see the main point for the root
disc. We've got a one minute aggregate with
a five minute prediction.
Yeah. And
now if we yeah. So then
okay. So it will still take some time
until it thinks we will be. So if
you increase the prediction time to, yeah, longer
and longer, eventually, we will get to
the point.
Boom. Yeah. Now But it's telling me my
desk is gonna fill up.
In
oh, I don't know how to read this.
Well, basically so yeah.
What what this does is for every
point in time in the past five minutes,
it calculates the value of that
from QL expression for you. You probably only
want to look at the current value, like,
what so if you go maybe it's better
to look at this in the table view
in this case.
So which tells, like, at the current point
in time,
what is the current prediction based on the
last one minute
five fifty thousand seconds into the future?
Right. Okay. And then what I'm saying is
that fifty thousand seconds under the future, I'm
actually gonna be a negative space on my
disk. Exactly. Exactly. So we could, like, fiddle
with that number to see when exactly it
reaches zero. So maybe
Trial and error. Yeah.
3,000.
It's for Emma. Oh, it's
fill up now. Is that what it's telling
me? Right. No. Of course. Yeah.
Yeah. Good enough. Good enough. So, you know,
like, in half an hour or something,
if if you still had the
look only five minutes in the future, then
it would alert you in, I don't know,
half an hour or something. Yeah. I I
guess what's what what is important here? Like,
for this scenario that I just could randomly
throw at you there is that if we
say, you know,
in twelve hours, what's that in seconds? Twelve
hours. I should know that. Right?
Right. 43,000.
Like, within the next twelve hours, will my
desk be in a negative value? That's what's
really important for me there. I know that
I should be risen and alert during office
hours to say, look, you may wanna and
and that's only for predictable growth based on
the prediction the linear prediction algorithm. You know,
it's not gonna detect
random bursts
and desk usage, but still, like, a a
good alert to have, I would suggest, probably.
Yeah. Yeah. And maybe just to
a bit of an idea of how to
use this in a
more sophisticated alert because this one alone is
maybe sometimes not enough. You wanna combine it
with, like, oh, the trend, but also combine
it with the total number of disk space.
Like, for certain disks have different trends or
or limits.
If you go to if you search for
cube dash Prometheus,
which is a project initially by oh, sorry.
No. Like, Google. Yeah. Yeah. Dash dash Prometheus.
Yep. That's fine. And then press t,
and then you press rules.
And then you go to the manifest slash
Prometheus rules. No.
Like the Yep. Watch one. Mhmm. And I
think you search for,
like, node file system avail, like, this this
metric name that we had. Yep. So this
is one example. For example, like, node file
system space filling up. You could actually paste
that over into PromLens, that expression.
Visualize
it.
Oh, so
The the
text field at the very top, you could
just, like, paste it in. Got it.
And
so the first thing that does is it
calculates
the the ratio
of available bytes to the total size
for each of the partitions. It multiplies it
by a hundred to get 2%
from ratio, 2%.
Then it filters, so it only gives you
those partitions that have less than 40%
available space.
So this is an alert that would with
just this this top stuff, it would alert
you for everything that has less than 40%
available space.
But now it adds an extra condition and
says, okay. And for those same label combinations,
it has to be true
that the linear prediction
over the last six hours,
and projected
one day into the future, this 24 times
60 times 60,
has to be also negative, less than zero.
Like, that's what we did. So
if it's if a file system
currently has less than 40%
free space and in one day is projected
to have zero, then we want to alert.
And there's actually more conditions further down.
If you scroll, there's, like, one more end,
which is like, okay. If it's read file
read only file system, we wanna ignore it.
So,
like, in practice, there's a few more conditions
you wanna add.
And it's it's always tricky also to get
this predict linear to
to work just right for your workload because,
like,
what exact
amount of history do you want to look
over and how far into the future?
You have some workloads that
generate, like, a sawtooth, and then they do
cleanup and go up again and do a
cleanup. And if you look over the wrong,
like, only over a couple of minutes and
predict too much far into the future, then
you might think, like, oh my god. The
disk is gonna fill up. But, actually, they,
you know, they do a cleanup way before
they actually fill up the disk. So kinda
need to know the workload on your machine
and
adjust
these alerts
accordingly. So it it is a bit tricky
still, but such is life. It's messy.
Exactly. Yeah. I think a lot of this
stuff is really just you gotta start collecting
the data first and then start to understand
how it changes and evolves over time and
write your queries. I don't I I mean,
I think Prometheus is a really good project.
It provides some really sensible defaults, but, you
know, teams probably only understand their own infrastructure,
their own use cases, and and adapt them
wherever possible for sure. Yeah.
Kubernetes is great.
Yeah. I I mean, we've not even looked
at
the at the Prometheus the Kubernetes integrations for
Prometheus yet. And, you know, we're just about
out of time. So maybe that'll be something
for another day where we can because as
as said, if we just summarize it, I
guess, in a few minutes, but
where we have been specifying our our targets
here
and and the the configuration fail itself, it's
not something we would necessarily have to do
with with Kubernetes
there. Is that correct?
Yeah. Yeah. You basically can have in the
extreme case, you could only have one scrape
config where you point it at the API
server and map everything over in the correct
ways, and then Prometheus will always have an
up to date view of what is in
your cluster. Now in real use cases, you
still have multiple scrape configs for certain things
a bit differently, and you can do black
box probing and, like, this external
probing that
and so on. There's, like, different things you
can do.
And
I guess, like, what are other areas we
haven't mentioned yet? We haven't even touched on
the alerts.
Yeah. We haven't set up alert manager. Like,
it's like a component that aggregates the alerts
of all your different Prometheus servers, can correlate
them, bunch them into one notification instead of,
like, a thousand,
give you nice human readable alert snippets on
Slack, PagerDuty ops ops genie, etcetera, etcetera.
There's so many there's, like, hundreds of open
source integrations to get metrics out of all
the things you care about. These are called
exporters.
There are
people building and also sometimes offering a SaaS
services
remote,
durable, scalable storages. So if you wanna keep
your data forever in a durable system, Prometheus
can send it there.
Yeah. There's so much more. Yeah. I
think what I what I'll say to the
people that are watching this, I will definitely
run more sessions on Prometheus. That's that's a
guarantee, especially with Kubernetes as as a service
discovery and looking at how we monitor Kubernetes.
I won't make you commit right here and
right now that you'll join me in those
sessions. Oh, got you. Yeah. For sure.
I was trying to give you a go
a jail free card there, but you you
you threw away. So Now, Julius is just
committed to joining me on on more exploration
of Prometheus within a Kubernetes context.
We just have a a comment from hacker
saying very interested in the lights and thank
you both. So Definitely, Julius. This has been
an absolute pleasure. It's been great to
to see Prometheus and, you know, play with
the exporter and really get a nice look
at PromLens. It looks like a really exciting
project, and I'm I'm I'm hoping that there's
a lot more to come there as well.
So thank you. Yeah. Thank you. That's been
fun.
I hope we got one
one comment popping on at the end there.
Let me see if I can read this
quickly. For example, I'm gonna have to work
on a fresh Laravel project. What would be
the first metrics you would like to monitor?
Give some examples, please. Yeah. Okay. We can
we can do this in in three minutes.
Right? So Laravel, don't know if you're familiar
with it, Julius, is a PHP framework. It
delivers web applications. So what do you have
any opinions? I certainly got a few I
can throw out as well on how what
metrics are important for a web application.
Yeah. For web application in general. So PHP
can sometimes be a bit challenging if it's
not a long running server that can actually
track metrics
over time, like these counters that, you know,
are supposed to only go up.
If you have such a situation,
just a general comment, you will immediately
need to, like, externalize your events to some
system that can aggregate them into counters. For
example, send them as statsty style metrics and
then use the stats d gateway that can
aggregate them over time and have Prometheus scrape
that. Just just one one thing. Not too
familiar with Laravel itself, but, generally,
with web applications,
the first things you start tracking are the
so called red metrics, r, e, and d.
So r stands for requests,
which is, like, basically counting how many requests
you've had and of which different types. Like,
maybe you wanna track each method or path
or status code a bit separately.
So a counter for that so then later
on, you can graph with the rate, like,
how many requests per second are you getting.
The second one, e, would be the errors.
So
if you don't already have it broken up
by status code or or, you know, if
if you have errors in your application, you
wanna count how many of which type are
happening. So then you can also alert on
that and graph that. And the d stands
for durations,
basically a distribution
of your latencies in your in your request
handling. So you could use a summary for
that if you never wanna aggregate over a
dimensions.
But, typically, probably, you would want to use,
like, a histogram metric for that to
track
the request latencies into buckets and then later
on calculate
percentiles from that and so on. So those
are the first ones, and then it depends
very much on the internals of an application,
what other stuff is happening in there. Are
there queues where you wanna expose the length
or, like, different other stuff? But,
yeah, those those are the the first metrics
that are, like, the obvious ones to add.
Yeah. Definitely.
I mean, I think the ones you've listed
there, they're probably libraries. I know that, you
know, PHP frameworks are very popular. They'll probably
handle most of the red metrics for you
handling how many request command, the response times,
the histograms, and all that. And it's really
important, like, Julius just said there as well,
to understand your own application and then met
your own instrumentation.
They actually understand your own domain. So
I think there's actually an open telemetry exporter
for Prometheus for PHP applications and PHP runtime
as well. So there's definitely loads of things
you can look at there, Robert.
Alright. Awesome. We have no more questions. I
will say thank you again, Julius. It was
a really insightful and a great learning experience.
So thank you for joining me, and I
look forward to our next session. Thank you.
That was a lot of fun. Be happy
to join again.
Alright. You have a nice day. I'll speak
to you soon. Thanks. You too. See you.